The joe rogan experience,
you know,
the styles of behavior and methods of
expression are being criticized and
critiqued. It this really radical
way and I think it's good.
I ultimately, I think there's a lot of
batch, I'd say it's good, but the, the,
the sentiment is good.
You know,
I think the reaction and some
of the overreaction, like
there's a spectrum, right?
There's, there's always gonna
be like, did you see the,
there was something that came
out yesterday from Portland
State University where
Peter Buck goes in and James Damore,
the Google memo guy and a Heather hiring.
She was a professor at Evergreen state
and I remember with the Jordan Peterson
gas, and she was actually on my
podcast last week with her husband,
Bret Weinstein.
Weinstein can't stay Weinstein.
I'm not thinking of the same person.
I was thinking of the person who got
fired because of, she did not get, fuck,
she ain't get fired, but she criticized
her for playing a Jordan Peterson thing.
Is that the same person?
No, no, no. That's Lindsey
Lindsey something. Yeah, sure.
She was in a different
university. Okay. Laurie.
Yay Canada. And in Canada,
another university in Canada, um,
this is important.
Anyway,
so they're in the middle of this
conversation and Heather, who is a,
she's a biologist and she starts going
over the biology of the differences
between males and females
that are just undeniable.
And these kids get up
and they started yelling,
this is bullshit and fuck you and power
to the people, all this crazy shit.
And then they tip over the sound
system and they're the most hilarious,
classical, liberal, progressive
lefties, green hair.
The guy has like this poofy Afro and he's
like, you know, we don't tolerate Nazis,
man. Like this is a fucking Nazis
or biologist. He's a shit, you know,
that's,
that stuff is the kind of stuff that
I think turns people off to the left.
Yes.
And almost provides a gateway to the
right where all of a sudden people can buy
into and even broader,
right wing ideology.
Because if you look at the left and
that's your perception of the left is it's
the people with the pink hair or the blue
hair and they're just going around and
their whole point is to Ddi platform.
People are sensor,
people are screaming about Ben
Shapiro or whatever the case is.
Like my whole thing is put,
if you're on the left,
and I think most lefties do this to be
fair, put the identity politics aside.
Okay.
And let's talk about the things that we
actually already have a majority of the
American people with us on. So you
know, like a classic leftwing idea.
Let's have a living wage.
The minimum wage is not a living wage
right now and you could work full time and
not make enough money to survive.
Well,
if you're on the left and you go out
there and you talk about we need to fight
to try to get a living wage and
make our government work for us,
well then you get everybody
to agree with you.
Even most Republicans agree with
you and you can go down the list,
whether it's legalizing marijuana is 60%
of the American people are not with us
ending the wars.
There was a poll that came out
in 2013 so it's old admittedly,
but only 17% of the American
people still want it to be in the,
in the war in Afghanistan. And we're still
there today. I'd imagine if anything,
that number probably dropped even
further and everybody's like,
what are we doing in
Afghanistan? Right. But it isn't.
The problem with polls is
when you ask people about it,
you're not asking them if they're
informed. You're just asking me.
You're just asking their opinion on it.
It what I was saying is about the left
versus the right is that the real problem
is anybody can be on either,
so you're going to get these people
that are going to disrupt this Heather
hiring,
you know,
lecture on biology from an informed
scientific perspective and like fuck,
this man is a patriarchy.
You're going to get that,
but you're also going to
get people like yourself.
You're also gonna get people that are
aware of the issues and educated and are
debating this in a very public way and
trying to figure out what's the best
possible solution to these things.
The problem is anytime you have a group,
whether it's pick the group gun owners,
vegans, what are anybody can fucking join
match and as soon as anybody can join,
you can't look at like
the worst case scenarios.
The green hair dork that kicks over the
microphone because they don't like the
idea that Heather is speaking
logically about biology. Like you know,
you have to look at like the the whole
thing. Sure. And we don't like to do that.
We'd like to point at the green
hair dork and say, hey liberals,
there's your left share.
Exactly. And you know,
the breakdown to me is when
you look at somebody like that,
they're in the category of what I would
call authoritarian left because they
want to control other people's actions.
They want to shut down that speech
and say, your ideas are so dangerous.
I don't even want to hear it. There's
a whole nother contingent of the left,
which again I would argue is
probably the majority of the left,
which is the libertarian left, which is
people like me and many others who say,
listen live and let live on social issues.
I'm never,
even though I don't agree with Steve,
Steven Crowder bench Shapiro on anything,
I'm never going to,
you know,
try to protest to get them to not speak
their mind at a school is foolish and it
makes it look like you don't
have an argument when you say,
I can't let that guy talk.
And then they get to go around and say,
I'm so persecuted because
I'm right. Right, right. You
know, meanwhile I say, okay,
you want to have somebody like that
go speak to college. Sure. Fine.
Let them speak. Let me get the
speech after. Well, it's good enough.
I mean I think open conversations
are critical and I also, uh,
I mean this is going to
probably be unpopular.
I don't think the way to do it is
in front of a large group of people.
I think you open yourself up
to a lot of grandstanding,
a lot of sang things just
for applause breaks a lot of,
there's a lot of bullshit.
It just,
it changes the nature of the
conversation because it becomes theater.
You're doing this thing in front of all
these people and you can hear a lot of
these times people say things like,
I'm a comic.
So I know when someone's saying things
for reaction, there's a way you do it.
Will you say it like this? And that's what
we want. And everybody goes, yeah, yeah,
you do not.
You do not talk like that when it's
just you and a person was just you and a
person.
You are just alone with your ideas.
And I think that is the way a guy
like Ben Shapiro and you know,
put whoever you want on the
left should have a discussion.
Yeah.
Um,
there's something about that,
that soft history, you know, like,
so you're not creating the best argument.
You're just trying to sound like you
have the best argument. And you know,
Bill Maher, for example, does this where
he's very good at the punchy one liners.
Sure.
Like he's in a conversation with his
panel on his show and he'll be like blah
blah blah blah. And there was, that's his
style. I mean he's a comic. Say anything,
you just can't, it was like a quick
partisan hacky point you made.
But since people already agree with
you in the audience, they clap.
So it's hard to flesh out the ideas.
And really that's why, listen,
I've always said,
I'm not the biggest fan of debate because,
so I've done a few debates and
people online like when I do debates,
but I'm not the biggest fan of debates
because I think it's like the WWE of
intellectual pursuits where you go in
this person's whole point is to defend
this side of it. My job is to defend the
other side of it and it's like, okay,
clash. But it's like, okay,
well then when we come across an issue
like the fucking 64 genders on Facebook
or whatever it is,
and I actually might agree and my now put
in a position where I'm supposed to be
like,
no,
I'm going to disagree because that's the
format of the thing that we're doing.
Right.
It's just weird and it's not normal.
I think that's actually very
important for both sides to do.
Like when there's something on
your side that you disagree with,
you should be honest about it.
And I even saying that,
that there's a side that there's sides
that there's our side versus their side.
We're, I think we're so inherently tribal
that we should resist any temptation
whatsoever to form teams,
especially about critical issues like it.
Really important social issues,
really important economic issues,
really important.
Civil rights issues.
These are just things that we should just
talk about without looking at them in
terms of, oh, the left wants this, so
I oppose it or the right ones this.
So I have to figure out ways to mock it.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah. I don't even know what to
say in response to that. I agree.
Would you say it's just,
you know,
it was when we were talking about this
before the podcast that like what I try
to do is have conversations with everyone.
I tried to have conversations
with nutty people like Alex Jones.
with rational people like
Sam Harris. I like to,
I tried to have conversations with
all kinds of people, but without fail,
every time I have a left wing person on,
I'm some cock left wing.
You know what's going to happen anytime
I have a right wing person on, um,
some outright Nazi apologist.
It's like this weird inclination we have
to try to label and categorize people
and I try to resist those labels
as much as humanly possible. Well,
I feel like what you're really good at
is you can have on people who disagree
completely on stuff,
but you'll kind of find a nugget of
agreement in the conversation with that
person and then you can expand on that
and you can end up having a very nice
conversation and you're not,
you never really anybody on to try to
like brow beat them and tell them that
they're wrong on this issue or that issue.
You know what I mean?
So I have no desire to do that. I
don't know. I mean, look, I've had,
I've had a lot of arguments in
my life and I don't like them.
I don't think they're beneficial.
I mean, I think debate is good,
but every time I've ever been
in an argument with someone,
like a real argument always come
out of it feeling gross. Yeah.
There are times in life or
arguments are necessary.
There's times in life where you're just
faced with aggression or conflict and
you have to do something about it.
You have to meet it head on.
There are times and likely that,
but whenever you can avoid that do,
and I think a lot of what arguments are,
and I failed at this in my life many
times, but a lot of what arguments are,
is the way you've reacted to the,
the thoughts and the expression
that another person has.
And if you just reacted a different way
or approached in a different manner or
took it into consideration a little
bit more before you responded,
I think the conversation
could have gone another way.
And I think I'm learning how to do that
more and more as they get better at
podcasting it better at conversations,
learning how to just settle someone down
and learning how to genuinely be a nice
person. So I don't, I don't
want to like insult anybody.
I don't want to be in a disagreement
with someone. I want to discuss ideas.
Okay.